David, I like the idea of single payer, but
how do you deal with increased demand for
medical services if single payer passes, if
everything is free at the point of care, people
are going to start going to doctors for all
sorts of procedures.
How do we deal with that?
This is sort of a ruse, OK?
And I like the I love the opportunity to talk
about this because there's so many different
things to consider.
First of all, let's apply the sniff test to
it.
If you're talking about unnecessary medical
procedures where people would get them for
kicks if it was free, what actually falls
under that umbrella that has no preventive
benefit?
What I mean by that is in every single payer
proposal, I've seen unnecessary cosmetic plastic
surgery.
That's not medically necessary.
It's not reconstructive in some way, for example,
wouldn't be covered by single payer.
You would still have to say, if I want breast
implants, if I want a nose job absent some
trauma or, you know, a mastectomy or other
situations, it's not covered.
I've got to pay for that out of pocket.
OK, so once you take cosmetic plastic surgery
off the table.
What what somebody who people are going to
get hip replacements just for kicks, even
though they don't really need them, people
are going to get, you know, dental cleanings
which reduce dental cleanings, reduce the
cost of care by preventing cavities as an
example and preventing gum issues.
So when you really get down to it, you could
see a decrease in demand for some of the more
resource intensive health care.
Preventive care reduces the number of E.R.
visits for heart attacks and strokes and abscesses
that could have been treated early on and
reduces demand for ICU and other acute services.
Because you're catching medical issues earlier,
you're addressing them earlier, and you prevent
some of that really expensive, specialized
care.
So no one, when you really think about it,
the things people are mostly not doing because
of financial obstacles aren't things people
do for fun.
And this gets to the most important point.
And really the fundamental reason why a for
profit health care system doesn't make sense.
Demand for most medical services is completely
inelastic.
OK, let's talk this through, and I hope I
can do this clearly going back to my microeconomic
days.
If you take a good look, for example, I don't
know Sharpies as an example where there's
lots of substitutes for Sharpies and Sharpies
are an item where you might prefer the Sharpie
to a pen, but you might not.
But there's subsidies, OK, etc..
If Sharpies are a penny, each demand explodes
tons of people.
If the Sharpie goes to a penny, I'll buy a
ton of sharpies and just use them, maybe instead
of a pen or some other marker.
If the Sharpie goes to a thousand dollars,
demand goes to almost zero.
Very few people like Sharpies enough to pay
a grand each and they'll switch to something
else.
You'll go to a pencil, you'll go to, you know,
whatever.
If there's no obvious alternatives, you'll
you'll you'll get Chalke.
I don't know.
OK, so that's there's elasticity there.
Significant elasticity.
When you take if you fall down and you need
a hip replacement, whether the hip replacement
costs a million dollars or a hundred thousand
dollars or twenty five thousand dollars or
ten thousand dollars or a thousand dollars,
my demand for a hip replacement is absolute.
If I need a hip replacement and it's essentially
zero if I don't need a hip replacement, no
matter how cheap you make hip replacements,
no matter how much access you give me to hip
replacements with single payer.
And of course, it ignores that a doctor wouldn't
recommend one if there's no reason to do it.
My demand for a hip replacement is zero.
So this is not a normal market.
Good.
And so the reality is, you know, consider
appendectomy.
I have I had an appendectomy a year and a
few months ago, up until the day on which
my appendix started swelling and requiring
to come out, my demand for appendectomy services
was zero.
Regardless of the cost.
I wouldn't even take a free appendectomy.
I wouldn't even take money to get an appendectomy.
Suddenly I need one and my demand is absolute.
OK, so this is the point.
The increase that people are expecting is
simply not going to be there from the standpoint
of people getting services they don't need.
Most of the services people would avail themselves
of if money were not an object are going to
be preventive services that actually reduce
acute disease in the long run and reduce costs.
So it's essentially a farce.
That's the reality.
And one last thing I know some people will
say.
But, David, when access to Medicaid is increased,
emergency room visits go up very, very different.
Medicaid is not Medicare.
Medicaid is primarily for poor or disabled
folks.
And in particular, it's folks who have a backlog
of more serious chronic issues than the average
population.
And it is not representative of what would
happen.
Bigger picture you have, there's very many
specific issues with that that make it not
analogous to what you would see.
Bigger picture.
All right.
So let me know if I'm missing anything, but
that's my general take on that.